in the Arctic Sky News filmed plastic
floating in front of a glacier in the
Antarctic we were with scientists as
they filtered it from seawater thousands
of miles from the nearest city but 99%
of ocean plastic is beyond the reach of
our cameras in the deep sea and
scientists have now found the highest
level of microplastics ever recorded 1.9
million pieces some smaller than a
millimeter covering one square meter of
the seabed off the west coast of Italy
the results were quite shocking to us so
we found incredibly high levels of
plastics on the sea floor and these were
mostly micro fibers and these fibers
that come from textiles so when you wash
your clothes
these fibers pass through waste water
treatment plants into rivers they're
flushed out to the sea where they can
sink to the bottom of the sea but at
least some micro plastics could be
avoided if manufacturers switch to the
right unlikely of sources for an
alternative Pease scientists at sampler
a start-up that's just had a significant
investment by Sky Ocean ventures have
found a way of taking plant protein and
rearranging the molecules to produce a
material strong enough to make tiny
capsules traditionally micro plastics
are present in many consumer products on
they are added to provide some
functionalities such as encapsulating
fragrance and but these materials may
take hundreds of years to degrade in the
environment so we have developed a novel
material that is capable of providing
that performance but may only take a
month to the great in the environment
enough micro plastic to make 10 billion
bottles a year in Europe alone is
deliberately added to everyday items
from detergents to paint using
biomaterials instead could help to
reduce the scourge of plastic in the
world's oceans Thomas More Sky News